you're just dark magician 69 69
69 69. we're still waiting for take-home
x-9 but still
we did it god damn it good job
so proud give yourself a pat on the back
right now doesn't it feel good
doesn't it feels good to know that you
made a difference you made the world
at least a percentage better
nothing changed well whatever you did
something
and for that i give you a thumbs up
you get the thumbs up pewdiepie seal of
approval then into a breakfast
but there's still one more thing
there's still one more thing left on the
table
what do people actually think about
things
that's what i ask myself every day oh
yeah what does teams react think about
that
if i don't get the approval of teens
react then what's the point
so let's just jump into it everybody and
see what teams react
has to say about pewdiepie
being uh subscribed to
by people let's jump into it
it gives me anxiety that they're so
close it's been the number one subscribe
for like so
long it's about time we have someone
else
[Music]
i hate you teens react
to subscribe to pewdiepie i saw this
video online
oh my goodness grab your phone go on
youtube search pewdiepie
and subscribe to a little pewdiepie
versus t series
i heard about this like a sub race or
whatever we're both trying to get to
like 69 million
we're both trying to get to 69 million
that's
that's that was the that's that's right
you gotta you got the story right
t-series is literally shaking
in the mud in the dirt going ah damn it
he got to 69 million before us back up
boys let's go back to india there's no
reason to keep uploading he already got
it that's right everybody
we already got it damn it feels good to
be on top
okay that's one way to do ads
that's the best way to do ads if you
don't want enough stupid women to
subscribe i don't know why i said that
because women aren't real everyone knows
this wake up t-series
t-series never heard of them never heard
of t-series t-series
is growing four times keep it that way
if you know what's good for you
t-series is growing four times faster
than pewdiepie
that kind of gives not anymore
not anymore over there not i'm miles
ahead
i could go to sleep forever i'd still
win
i don't do anything pewdiepie won't be
the number one most subscribers godzilla
what what are all these channels where
are they coming from
oh god am i going to pay am i going to
be passed by another one now what is
that police okay please
no and he's got the 420. i didn't want
to pull this card
but there's only one number that means
more than 69.
9 11. just kidding that's not funny
it was kind of funny half a second it
was funny and then it stopped being
funny and i acknowledged that it's not
funny anymore but hey
he's been the number one subscriber for
like so long it's about time we have
someone else
how could you say that therefore i spent
all my money on ads so he can remain the
number one most subscribed to channel
in the world absolute mad lad what a
legend never been so proud
this guy's the ultimate homie he's
helping him out i'm not hating on
anybody that is like pure dedication but
i would not
do that okay well i hate on you for
saying that how about that take some
responsibility
and do your part dude i love mr beast
he's so
funny like every one of his videos is
original
is that it was that a dis to me what do
you mean every one of mr b's video
i have original okay fine maybe i don't
but that's why we go so great together
me and mystery perfect match we complete
each other i have absolutely nothing of
value
and then we have creative original ideas
damn maybe we should create a channel
together maybe a record company
so we can beat t-series at their own
game calling all bros you can save
youtube
oh my god unsubscribe from t series
truer words have never been spoken i
wonder how many people
saw the ad you're driving home from work
you see the billboard and you're like i
need to pull over right now
i need to subscribe to pewdiepie right
now that person in that red car right
there they literally just have to stare
at pewdiepie's face like the entire time
he's just like hey this is so funny what
the hell it's so distracting on the road
lucky fan whoever's driving that honda i
envy you
are you subscribed to pewdiepie can you
subscribe to him please
you every little bit counts see this guy
gets the idea
if we work together well we already did
it it doesn't matter
okay i have never seen an ad out of you
i know before
millions of people every year are
affected by awkward handshakes
he met conan that was awful that was
awful
thank you conan he met conan that was
how much money did this cost honestly
like
getting all these ads are you subscribed
to pewdiepie uh
no where were you when this happened oh
my god
i need you to subscribe to him here
chris can you hold that for you i'll
hold all your stuff
are they like on a college campus right
now that's so funny i'm not
sure the viewers can see it but all
right hit subscribe
thank you dude this guy is really going
at it right thank you here you go here's
some ketchup
subscribe to pewdiepie everybody free
ketchup what we do have
is original content i feel like i wanna
go subscribe to help him out and the
most
accurate news source this planet has
that would definitely get me to
subscribe if i wasn't already
67 million subscribers in a night he
crossed many bridges to get where he is
today
really you really really you got to do
me like that
can't believe someone would do this
leave a like if you are depressed
what what pd5's fans
have been thanking mr beast as well as
trying to do their part to keep
pewdiepie number one and so we have some
memes around that to show you now
awesome okay looking forward to it
subscribe to pewdiepie oh my god
like that's the first thing that pops up
google i'm doing my part it's so
it's so it's so random like this is so
dumb that's cute that's cute
even google knows what's up mr b's
impact
plus 85 462 subscribers
yeah it's even more now it's pretty
crazy it's like this thing is even
bigger than i
am now wait that that's not possible
low-key i'm part of the nine-year-old
army
actually haiky what am i talking about
subscribe to pewdiepie there you go
there you go he understood finally he
was like oh god i got to do my part
there you go well done bought a small ad
space in my local newspaper and
published this i did my part pewds help
pewds be
the first one to reach 69 million
subscribers
in the newspaper so we get the old
people to subscribe to there are still
newspapers people
do you know about that this was still a
thing i want to know how many people
clicked on that
link i think you can if you hit a plus
after
2 600 people get 2
600 people clicked it works
elon musk send me your dankest memes
pewdiepie meme review when midnight
right subscribe to pewdiepie on your
next rocket launch
that's the thing though you can't mess
around with elon musk like that because
you know he'll do something like that
people are really really involved in
this this is so stupid like
literally so stupid for this many people
to care about it i'm confused
i'm i'm entertained that was
that was pretty crazy the internet is
reacting how the internet reacts to a
lot of things just
kind of blowing it out just so that way
it can have it's like moments of fame
and get those last little subscribers no
no but
what you're saying are you saying that
i'm just getting subs now
and then after a month or so no one will
care
god damn it were you aware that the most
subscribed youtube channel was possibly
about to change
no i literally did not know this channel
even existed
i didn't even know that was like even
happening i wasn't aware at all i mean
i i'm not even subscribed to pewdiepie
some people are just cruel now i will
originally social blade predicted that
t-series would pass pewdiepie and
subscriber count on october 21st of this
year but this gap began to slow down and
is now estimated that it will pass by
november 14th
right they're still winning what no i
i i thought they gave up fine
it seems that we got the teens on our
side but let's see
what the youtubers are saying the
youtubers react
when you see how like t-series has taken
off it's shocking
that pewdiepie has so many subscribers
[Music]
okay try guys what did you try and leave
good one so the channel is called
t-series
he's heard of t-series i haven't it's
not really a fair comparison
one guy and you know editors and whatnot
versus
massive corporation with thousands of
employees
it's different there should be like
different buckets on youtube
one for like the youtubers and the other
for like this is a big company goddammit
jordan
well said level 10 book excellent
good take the only good take i've seen
in this video t-series vs pewdiepie i
mean pewdiepie is very very youtube
right
it's man speaking at cameras yeah
honestly when you see how
like t-series is taking off it's
shocking that pewdiepie has so many
subscribers
i don't like how they laugh like that
okay don't laugh at me like that they
mostly post bollywood
music soundtracks and film trailers
t-series is also the world's most viewed
youtube channel with over 47
billion views that high oh my god and
they're gaining almost 100 000
subscribers a day 100
000 new subscribers every single day oh
my god
i gotta get onto this t-series what do
you think it is about them that could
make them potentially the number one
channel of all time
it's like the only place to go to for
that type of content
[Music]
that's right congratulations you got
monopoly do you know how many
scruffa-looking awkward
boomers ranting about different topics
into a microphone and a camera there are
on youtube do you understand how tough
it is on this market
to do what i'm doing so many have made
the argument that it isn't fair to
compare the two channels since t-series
is a full-fledged network and company
that uploads multiple videos per day
created by many different artists
versus pewdiepie who is an individual
creator who developed his following
entirely through youtube
yeah well i mean good good for pewdiepie
because
you know he did it for this long still
doing it
still doing it thank you whenever you go
on trending you always see like uh
like the jimmy kimmel show or you just
see like the next uh
netflix trailer it's it's it's getting
to that point where
it's going to be a global market of just
different production companies
damn damn that's depressing to think
about isn't they
i guess i never thought about it that
way things are always changing on
youtube i think that's what makes it
interesting that's what makes it fun no
one saw it coming but and it's such a
quick
time frame as well for my 11 years on
youtube
i've seen time and time again the
top five positions be uh creators on
youtube
maybe i remember it differently but when
i started off there was a bunch of
there was more companies being being big
on youtube
but uh creators kind of took over i
wonder if the same sort of trend will
apply to
india now and maybe we'll see the actual
independent indian creators
the appeal and the value of investing in
youtube content it will
more and more be taken over by companies
logically thinking
it's going to become more and more
comprehensive corporate there's just so
many giant companies trying to keep up
with youtube
and if they want to stay in business
it's almost obligated at this point to
do something
i know there's you know even creators
that are just
actors in channels and they don't
actually own the channel
i mean just look at smosh you know it
came out a few days ago that smosh
actually sold their channel and
they're really just employees for smosh
and all this time you think
it's a private channel it's it's just
another company and i wonder if that
applies to other channels i don't think
a lot of people realize that for example
i'm glad i'm independent at least that's
about the only thing i had good thing i
have working out for me right now
you can't compete with that as an
independent but you know you shouldn't
be thinking of it as a competition
anyway
there's plenty of people and views out
there for all of us
no i need more
i need more subscribers god damn it
meanwhile pewdiepie 2012.
like half a million it's amazing it's a
huge number
uh you know i'm really happy about it
but still it's
it's just a number and what really
matters to me at least
uh it's the support that you bros show
in all your videos that's
like if that's what really means
something
i think it means shut up felix anyway i
hope you guys enjoyed this video you
know what to do that's right
that's what i thought see you tomorrow